كما اشرت وهناك مجموعه من الاخبار
العاجله قبل قليل ذكرته وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه ان هؤلاء الافراد يواجهون الان
تهمه اسقاط الدوله الاستخبارات تتحدث انهم
موجودون في الوحده الخاصه وفي جنود
الاحتياط لو عدنا قليلا الى الى الوراء
طبعا ساعات كيف تم الكشف عن هذا العدد وعن
وصولهم الى هذه الوحدات الخاصه وهمم
والجيش
طبعا هذه ليست اول عمليه نحن نركب هذه
العمليات ونشاهدها على الدوام في المانيا
وهذا الامر يخلق السلطات لكن ما فضى الكاس
هي حرب اوكرانيا
التداعيات والغضب من هذه الحرب وتدعيه
الاقتصاديه والان
ظهر مدلول جديد في المانيا بما يسمى الفقر
الطاقه نحو ااه نحو واحد من كل اربعه
المانيا الان يعاني من ارتفاع
تكاليف طاقه هذا الامر في الحقيقه حرب
اوكرانيا هي التي هي التي افاضت الكاس
خصوصا ان الكثير من الاصوات التي التي
تحسب على مواطنها رايق هي في الحقيقه هي
من تصنيف اليمين التقليدي الذي تتهم
السلطات موسكو بانها تحاول اللاعب بورقته
بد وبانه هناك همم اختراقا روسيا داخل هذا
التنظيم من اجل خلط الاوراق في المانيا
شهيدنا ذلك ايام الانتخابات وما بعده
وتحذيرات متكرره سواء من الاستخبارات
الداخليه او الخارجيه بان موسكو ستلعب على
ورقه الغضب الشعبي
فقط اذا سمحت فقط
الاعتقال الاوليه لعدد من العناصر تابعين
لحركه مواطنه الرايخ